[Music]
welcome back so in the last lecture I
introduced the randomized SVD which is a
very computationally efficient algorithm
to extract the dominant rank or singular
value decomposition from a large data
matrix X if we believe that it has low
rank intrinsic rank R now in practice
you don't actually want your random
projection matrix to have exactly our
columns that's not the most effective
thing so there's two techniques that can
help one is called over sampling and
that's essentially a technique where you
just add a couple maybe five or ten
extra extra columns to this random
projection matrix so you make it just a
tiny bit bigger and you have much much
much better chance of capturing the
dominant subspace of X when you do this
even for a relatively small additional
cost
okay so always recommend it to over
sample by five or ten columns if
possible there's good rules of thumb the
other thing that's really useful is
something called power iterations and
this one is especially useful if your
data matrix is not exactly as low rank
as you want it to be so in lots of cases
what you want is for your data matrix to
have really really low rank structure
and then some small singular values in
which case you can probably approximate
this rank are the dominant are singular
values up here using these methods but
often times what your data matrix
actually looks like is you have a much
slower drop-off in singular values and
so what you can do is by essentially
taking powers of X and you know X is a
rectangular matrix so I'll tell you what
I mean by taking powers of X in a minute
you can essentially you know this is the
singular value distribution of X but the
singular value distribution of x squared
you would square all of these so the
little ones become even littler and so
by taking power iterations you can
essentially drive this singular value
distribution down until it looks more
like what you want it to look like okay
and so the way that you actually
you that you would introduce this matrix
X to the power Q which is equal to X
times X transpose to the power Q times
your original data matrix X now you
don't actually ever compute this massive
square matrix to compute X to the power
Q but instead when you're projecting X
down to with P you essentially multiply
it on the left by X transpose and then
again by X and you do that again and
again and again q times okay so this is
absolutely more expensive it requires
more passes through this really big data
matrix and that's often the expensive
part is you know I have to multiply I
have to go through this whole data
matrix at least once to compute this the
sketch Z if I use power iterations if I
use Q power iterations I have to go
through Q more passes of my data matrix
X so it can be a lot more expensive but
again it also gives much much better
performance if you have slower decay and
your singular values and you want them
to look like they decay faster so if you
really want to capture the first are
singular values and they don't decay
that rapidly you're gonna need to do
power iteration even though it comes
with this extra cost of more passes
through your data and of course passes
through your data is very expensive
because who wants to multiply a billion
by million matrix at more times than you
need to okay
there are guaranteed error bounds for
the approximation performance of this
low rank singular value decomposition
based on things like their rank the
singular value distribution the amount
of oversampling the amount of power
iterations and so on and so forth the
simple formula is in our book in section
1.8 but there are more elaborate
formulas in the literature that have
tighter bounds that can give you really
really good guidelines for how to choose
these values for for your particular
application okay so next we're going to
code this up on some examples thank you